So with these, state transition diagrams there are several problems that
we've noticed. There are too many arrows, there are too many states, and
there's no concept of nesting in them. As far as the arrows are concerned,
if you've got end states and you've got impossible events. You've got n times m,
a multiplicative number of possible arrows.
As far as states are concerned we've already indicated that the number of states
goes up with the power of the number of possible things that can be going on.
As far as nesting is concerned with the example of the dialing the telephone.
In, in essence we would like to have done the modeling by having the,
the entering of the particular digits somehow hidden within that dialing state.